we have an update now to a story that  our eight news now i-team broke last  week the jury siding with pizza chains  to borrow in a lawsuit from a once  undocumented worker who said that her  restaurant manager repeatedly sexually  assaulted her well in that lawsuit  Sandra Perez claimed her manager also  threatened her with deportation at the  now closed location which was inside the  Monte Carlo here's part of what she told  the i-team nobody cares  and now I'm the example that nobody  cares because I was screaming for help  nobody  well apparently the jury siding with the  company and the manager after a 10-day  trial sabaro's CEO telling us quote we  are thankful that the jury recognized  sabaro's immediate and thorough response  when Perez's allegations were brought to  our attention the lawsuit had claimed  the company moved her to a second  location in retaliation we're still in  awaiting a response from her attorneys